I'm Francesc Campoy.
And today, I'm going to be
talking about Google Cloud
Spin.
Just to have a basic
idea, how many of you
know what Google Cloud Spin is?
How many of you have actually
taken a photo with it?
Only one.
Wow.
And me too.
So you're going to see
what Google Cloud Spin is.
It's a demo that we
built. Lots of fun.
And the whole thing is
I'm going to show you
how we actually made it
with all the fails included.
There were a lot of them.
So the idea was,
OK, so let's build
a demo for GCP NEXT 2016, which
was a month ago, actually,
in San Francisco.
And we had two options.
Well, we had a couple options.
We had a couple of constraints.
We needed to be able
to make it in two weeks
with basically no budget,
which is always fun.
We're four people, and there
was actually three weeks.
But in the meanwhile, it was
my birthday, and someone else,
there were holidays in
the middle, lots of fun.
So we decided let's just
reuse the one we already have
from 2015, which is Abelana.
And if you are interested,
it's an Instagram clone,
and it's open sourced.
So you can take it out.
It's a pretty simple app.
It's more of an Android
app more than a Cloud app.
But there is some image
processing on the back.
That's pretty cool.
Then someone came with the
idea, like, hey, slow-mo
is the thing everybody does.
Why don't we do slow-mo?
It's like, Android does
slow-mo. iOS does slow-mo.
Awesome.
But where is the Cloud?
Yeah, no.
But what if we could
do slower than slow-mo?
What if we could stop time?
And we had this idea where,
basically, it's like, OK,
so I love "The Matrix,"
at least the first one.
So what if we took all of these
pictures at the same time,
as they do, by using
100 cameras surrounding
Keanu Reeves in the middle?
And then we use all
of those pictures
to generate this
animation that makes
the effect of stopping time?
I was like, that is awesome.
And then I went to my
manager, I was like, hey,
I want to buy 100 cameras.
And he was like, no.
Which I understand.
So how do you reduce the budget?
Well, two ways.
Instead of 100 very
expensive cameras,
let's reuse 20 phones
we already have.
So we had 20 Android
phones together.
And then instead of having
Keanu Reeves or whoever,
just have me.
Much cheaper, I guarantee.
And this is what we did.
We had 20 phones.
And then we talked to
our friends in Android,
it was like, hey, so we want
to take 20 pictures exactly
at the same time
over the network.
And they were
like, sure, try it.
And that's pretty
much what you get.
You get 20 pictures that
are around the same time,
but definitely not good enough.
And then we had this idea.
OK, so instead of taking
pictures, let's make a video.
So what we do is we
have a 6 seconds video.
Now that variability of
when the picture is taken
is now when the video
starts, which is fine,
because then we're going to
use it like on the movies.
We're going to use that clap.
[CLAP] And that's my
animation for clap.
And that's going to be
the synchronization point.
And then we stop the video.
Cool.
So once we had the idea and
pretty much the concept,
we created this beautiful,
beautiful diagram.
This is an engineering
diagram, basically, it
shows there's a circle,
there's degrees, and that's it.
So 19 phones, then degrees,
180 degrees, everything works.
We're happy.
And then we sent
this to marketing,
and they were like, yeah,
it's going to look like this.
And we're like,
yeah, that is cool.
That is much better.
And that's actually
how it looks like.
This is the first
time we did it.
This is in New York.
And this is really cool.
And this is one of
the first trials
we did with the whole demo.
And I hope you're going
to be able to hear.
There's two important
things here.
One is listen to the noise,
the background noise, and also
the beep.
And also, pay attention to
where the black duct tape goes.
[CRACKLING]
[BEEP]
That's my head.
Yes.
So the important
thing is that you
hear that noise, the background
noise, that is part of life.
There's background
noise everywhere.
You have to deal with it.
But we need to find
that noisy frame,
and then from that
noisy frame, we're
able to extract one image,
which is this image here.
Then we have 19 phones, so we
extract more, more, more, more.
And then we put it together.
And then we stop time,
which is pretty amazing.
And it looks
really, really cool,
taking into account that
everything you need here
is just a bunch of
phones and writing code.
So the backend architecture,
how does this work?
Well, we upload videos.
Magically, we process them.
We extract a single
frame from that video.
Then we put all those
frames together,
and we stitch them into one
single animation, video,
or GIF.
And then we display it.
And this is the whole thing.
Now the next step is like,
sure, how do you do this?
And that's the rest of the talk.
So the first part is,
how do I tell 20 phones,
take a picture now,
at the same time?
And every single
one of the phones
knows what's their ID, what
is the picture quality that I
want, all the things that you
need to specify for a picture?
Well, let's see,
actually, this demo now.
It's going to give you a
bigger idea of what kind
of synchronization we need.
This is Ray, one of the guys
that helped with the demo.
And you can see all the phones.
And they're green.
That's because they're
ready to record.
Then we have that tablet that
said, OK, start recording.
Yellow means wait a second,
I'm starting to record.
Blue means I'm recording.
Then Ray jumps.
We press a button.
And actually, that
button sends the audio
through all the cables.
And then we have
this dashboard that
is going to be showing
everything that is going on.
So the videos now
are being uploaded.
We were over conference
Wi-Fi, so good luck with that.
But it takes a little bit.
But now, all those
[INAUDIBLE] it
means that we're now
extracting the frames.
You can now see the frames.
And once all the frames have
been extracted together,
we'll be able to actually stitch
them together and generate
the image.
The cool thing is that this
dashboard was created two days
before the demo.
And how was it possible for
us to build these things
so easily?
It was actually because the
synchronization mechanism
that we used was very powerful.
Almost there.
Yeah, the Wi-Fi still upsets
me when I see the video.
I know it's going to
happen, but still.
There you go.
The last video gets
uploaded, extracted.
We stitch everything
together and then
we put it into
the upload bucket.
And then you get Ray.
Ray is about to jump.
The picture was taken
a little bit too early.
That's actually kind
of the hard part of it.
So we want to be able to
synchronize a bunch of devices.
We want real-time notifications.
Start recording has
to happen right now.
You cannot wait.
If you wait for too long,
the video is only 6 seconds.
You will miss it.
We need to be able to
have diverse clients.
We've seen the Android
phones, but we also
have things like our
web dashboard needs
to be able to get that data.
And then our extractors,
our stitchers,
and all the other
workers need to be
able to also modify the status.
And then also, I don't want to
be pulling data all the time.
Is this frame ready?
No.
I just want to say, just let
me know when this is ready.
And obviously, we used Firebase.
Why did we use Firebase?
Well, because this
console is pretty amazing.
The fact that I can see
what's going on in my system
before building any dashboard,
for me, that's a huge thing.
Especially when
you're debugging,
and you have weird
bugs like, oh, someone
misspelled this
name on this field.
Things happen.
So the fact that you're able
to see it here so easily
is pretty powerful.
It has three main clients, for
JavaScript, iOS, and Android.
And in Java, this is
a part of the code
that we have to be
able to send the status
of the current camera.
So we're saying, camera
number 1 is ready to record,
and it's getting input from
external mic or internal mic.
We actually care
about that a lot,
so when we show the state,
external mic is green,
internal mic is yellow.
And if something
fails, it's red.
So at least from
the tablet, you're
actually able to see the
status of all the phones.
You're also able to modify the
ISO for the pictures, which
is very cool.
Because imagine if
you had to change
the ISO in every single
phone separately.
We did that once, only once.
And as I said, we had these
three library clients.
But my favorite API, which
one do you think it is?
Rest API because
I'm a Cloud man.
And the cool thing
about Rest API
is then you can build
things on top of it.
And I'm also a Gofer.
So you can actually
write in Go things
like this that will
modify Firebase from Go.
And this works perfectly,
and it's super nice to use.
So I was very happy with this.
The stitcher is written
in Go completely,
and it uses Firebase.
So the extractor is
written in Python.
It also uses the API, but
it uses the bare Rest API
without any client
library on top.
So we have Firebase
in the middle.
How does this work?
Well, we upload the
videos with Firebase,
and we tell the dashboard.
We extract the frames,
we tell Firebase,
and we tell the dashboard.
We stitch all the
frames, we tell Firebase.
And then we display the result,
and everything is in Firebase.
So the thing is that
dashboard was created two days
before the demo.
Why?
Because all the data
was already there.
Everything we had to
do was basically just
map it into some cute
way of displaying it.
That was very powerful.
So media storage,
let's talk about how
we store all of those videos.
So we have three places
where we have to store
videos, media in general.
We have our videos,
we have the frames,
and then we have the
generate animations.
And there's a
couple requirements
that we have on this.
First of all, these are videos.
And every single
one of those videos
is between 10 and
20 megs depending
on what you're actually doing.
But what if we wanted
to do extra things?
Or what if our animation starts
to get pretty cool, pretty
crazy, and we started to
have gigabytes of video?
Maybe terabytes?
Nah, terabytes, no.
But what if we had
terabytes of data?
We need to plan for that.
Also, we want to be able to
say as soon as a frame has been
extracted, and I
put it in the disk,
I want anyone to be
able to go and read it.
I don't want something that
was like, put it there,
and then I read it directly,
and I'm like, wait, what?
And then two seconds later,
oh, yeah, the file was there.
Sorry.
That is what we call
eventual consistency.
I do not want that
for this system.
And then finally, it'd be very
sweet of every single time
there's a new file, a new
video, that has been uploaded,
I could get a
notification from it.
We have three options to store
data on Google Cloud Platform.
There's actually a fourth
one, Cloud Bigtable.
I will not mention it other
than it is a very, very, very
big table.
So if your tables
are not that big,
maybe don't even consider it.
But we have Datastore.
Datastore is for structured
data that is non-relational.
Our data is not structured.
It's a video.
We cannot do that.
SQL is structured data
again that is relational.
Again, we have
unstructured data.
We cannot use it.
The last one, Cloud Storage.
What do we use
Cloud Storage for?
Everything else.
You can store cat videos, and
GIFs, and whatever you want.
A little bit of the marketing
aspect of Google Cloud Storage.
You can store terabytes
of data, which
is way more than a GIF
will ever be, I hope.
It is very reliable.
There's three flavors,
and we'll see them later.
But the highest
availability that we provide
is 99.9% availability,
which is really good.
And it's also replicated
across many regions, which
means that if, for any reason,
a Google data center disappeared
into the void, you could
still not lose data
because your data is actually
replicated in many data
centers.
And then it actually has
that change notification
that we wanted.
We're going to be able to get
notifications every single time
something happens
in our storage.
So the three flavors that I
mentioned before are Standard.
And Standard is the
fastest, the most available.
And all of them are exactly
the same durability.
Important thing.
Durability is, will
we lose your data?
And the answer is no.
The durability is
always to the top
in every single one of them.
Standard is the one that we're
using because we want something
that will allow us to access the
information very quick and very
often.
If you don't need
that information
to be available all the time,
but you want it to still
be pretty quick,
imagine [INAUDIBLE],
you can use Durable Reduced
Availability Storage.
It's less available, but the
durability is still there.
And finally, we have Nearline.
And Nearline is basically when
you want to store a lot of data
that you will never read
until you have a bug,
and then you will
want to read it,
and it's really
important it's there.
So all the durability
is there, but instead
of taking milliseconds to
download the files that you
put there, you're going to have
to wait an incredible amount
of seconds.
So it's not hours.
It's just seconds.
A little bit of Android code.
I'm not a Java person, so
every single time I see so many
[INAUDIBLE] it's like [GROAN].
But you first build a
storage with Storage Builder.
Basically, you give all the
authentication and stuff
like that to be able to say
this is my storage client.
Then I create a storage object.
That is the file
that is going to be.
And then we have a
file input stream.
I will actually upload
my video into the output.
And what could go wrong?
Exceptions?
Yeah, sure.
There are some exceptions
to be handled there,
but it doesn't fit in the code.
So just don't copy paste
into production yet.
Cool.
So let's talk about Object
Change Notifications.
Object Change
Notifications allows us
to every single time there's
a change in our bucket,
we're going to get a
notification sent to a webhook.
And you can set
that up with gsutil.
That's it.
You say, hey,
gsutil notification,
watch this bucket, and send
changes to that webhook.
So now when one of my
phones uploads a video,
that video will
generate a notification
sent to my notification
processing endpoint.
We'll see what that
is in a minute.
And what is in
that notification?
Well, it's an HTTP POST request
that has a lot of things
inside.
But we care only
about the fact there's
the name and the bucket.
So you get the name of the
file and what happened to it.
It's like, hey, there's a new
file, and there's the name.
So then inside,
we're going to be
using a convention
for the file structure
to decide what picture
is that, what phone is
that, and all of these things.
Cool.
So for the buckets, we
have everything solved.
Meanwhile, on the
hardware side of things,
that I'm very happy
not to partake,
this is Matt, one
of our interns.
And he wrote the first version
of the sound structure.
Matt is a very smart intern.
And I think he's now a Googler.
I'm not sure.
He's trying to figure out why
this lamp doesn't turn on.
When I saw this, I thought,
it's mounted backwards.
No.
It's actually mounted correctly.
But it is not plugged.
So that is a problem.
Yeah.
He's still a very smart guy.
He wrote really good code.
This was our first
version of Cloud Spin.
There's actually a previous
version to this one.
I could not find
a picture of it.
But before having tripods,
we had selfie sticks.
So we had 20 selfie sticks
with phones on them.
Really not stable.
I do not recommend.
Yeah.
We did not break any
of the phones, which
I don't know how that happened.
But yeah, so that was our first
iteration of the processing.
Back to the software
side of things.
So we have those
notifications that
are now being sent somewhere.
We have to be able
to handle them.
How do we do it?
Well, we need to be able to
handle HTTP POST request.
We saw that that's what we had.
And we're going to need
to decode that JSON file,
that JSON object.
We need to do authentication.
And we're going to do
authentication two ways.
We're going to do
authentication to make sure
that the notification
we're receiving
is actually a notification
from the bucket
and not something
that someone might have
forged, which is something
that we actually got.
He was a Googler, but he
was basically trolling us,
and he did.
So we decided to add
authentication on that side.
And also, we need
authentication to be
able to communicate safely
with the rest of our system.
And we want that
to be easy to do.
And then we're going to
need to also use task queues
or push tasks.
And we're going to see how
those work in a minute.
So we're going with App Engine.
And why did we go
with App Engine?
Well, we need
something that will
be able to reply
to ACB requests,
and that is what App
Engine was made for.
I am very happy to write
in Go, so all of those
are written in Go.
And Go is one of the
languages supported
by App Engine classic.
There is Java, PHP,
Python, and Go.
And it has a lot of constraints.
You cannot spend more than 60
seconds to reply to a request,
which we're totally
fine with it.
You cannot access the file
system in the machine,
totally fine with it.
So awesome.
On the good side of things is
that I get to just send my code
and forget about it.
There's no DevOps.
I don't choose how many
machines or which machines
should run this thing.
And if, for any reason,
I have a lot of traffic,
it would just
autoscale directly.
There's a lot of
companies that use this.
Khan Academy, Angry Birds,
and all of these people
that have very varied traffic,
and you have traffic spikes,
App Engine manages that
very well for them.
So we have two flavors.
And they changed names
not that long ago.
They used to be called
App Engine in Managed VMs.
And now, they're called App
Engine Standard Environment,
which is the one that
I was talking about.
You're running a sandbox,
and everything is awesome
as long as you match the
constraints that we have.
And then we have App Engine
Flexible Environment.
And App Engine Flexible
Environment, basically,
give as a Docker container,
and it will run it for you.
And this is really cool, because
basically, all of a sudden,
you have the good
things about App Engine,
it will scale as
much as you need.
It will not start as fast
because it is not a sandbox.
It is a VM now.
So your scaling will not be
as fast as classic App Engine.
So if you can do
classic App Engine,
I could still say go with
Standard Environment.
But if you need
to Go plus FFmpeg,
for instance, which is
an awesome library that
doesn't run on
Standard Environment,
you could do it on a
Flexible Environment.
So we wrote a Go App Engine
App, and now we're good.
Except that we're missing the
whole part that does things.
So how do we manage the fact
that, OK, I got a notification.
I want to send it somewhere.
I could send it to the
machine that is doing
the extraction of the frames.
But what if that
machine is down?
What if there's many machines?
Which one should I send it to?
Do I need a load balancer?
Kind of complicated.
Instead, what I'm
going to do is I'm
going to use a messaging system,
asynchronous messaging system.
Why do I want that?
Well, for availability,
if all of my machines
are down because I'm
upgrading, or maintaining,
or I broke it-- things
happen-- I don't
want people to get errors.
I want them to
just wait a couple
more seconds till
that new VM is up,
and that will be able
to handle the message.
So that will actually
absorb those problems.
Also, if you have
too much traffic,
I don't want to DDoS
my own machines.
I want those messages to be
there for a little bit longer.
Yes, you will wait for
a little bit longer,
but my machines
will not go down.
And then also, if
there's any outage,
no one needs to see that.
Only me.
On the other hand, there
is better throughput.
So imagine that you have, all of
a sudden, 1 million videos that
arrive at the same time.
And I send 1 million requests
to my three sad machines.
What will happen?
Not a single video
will be processed.
All of the machines
will go down.
And the new ones
will go down again.
So sad state of things.
Instead, with that
messaging, I'm
going to have a stable
throughput, which
is as much as machines can
deal with, and then you wait.
And then you have
timeouts and things
like that if you really
want to say, oh, yeah,
it took too long.
So we're going to
put two queues-- one
before the extractors and
one before the stitchers.
And we're going to need
asynchronous messaging.
And also pull subscriptions.
And why do we need
pull subscriptions?
First of all, what are
Basically, pull
subscriptions are
the ones where I'm going to
say, is there a new message?
And then the queue is going
to say, yes, there you go.
And then I'm going
to process it.
And once I'm done, I'm going
to say, hey, I'm done with it.
If, for any reason, I
fail or I forget to say,
oh, I'm actually done, after
a couple seconds, minutes,
you choose, that task
will be timed out
and will be available
in the queue again.
So if, for any reason, your
process fails, which happens,
your task will still
be processed later on.
Push subscription,
on the other hand,
is I just send you a message
and say, this is a new message.
And then you have x amount of
seconds to reply saying, OK,
done.
So we used Cloud Pub/Sub.
Cloud Pub/Sub is exactly this.
And why did we use Pub/Sub?
Because it's very flexible
and very powerful.
We're going to see in a
minute how it actually works.
But basically, it provides
real-time communication,
many-to-many, and
completely decoupled.
And this is something
important for some experiments
that we do later.
So how does this work?
Well, publishers send
messages to topics.
And then those topics have
subscriptions, as many of them
as you want.
When they send a
message to a topic,
that topic will be sent
once per subscription.
So you can, there,
multiply your messages.
And then for every
subscription, you
have a bunch of subscribers.
And every message that
gets to a subscription
will be sent to one of
the subscribers, which
means that all of a sudden,
you can have one-to-one if you
want, one-to-many as you choose.
This is really
powerful because if you
want to add topics
or subscriptions,
you don't need to tell
neither the publishers
or the subscribers.
You can add things
on top quite easily.
You can use it from anywhere.
There's a Rest API.
Rest APIs are awesome.
So you can use it
from Go, from Android,
from a Raspberry Pi hidden
under your bed, whatever
you want to do.
In our case, we use
it in two places.
We used it for the
extraction topic
where we have a
lot of extractors.
And only one of those extractors
will receive that message
and process our video.
And then all the extractors
will send the extracted frames
to the stitch topic.
And then the stitcher will
receive all the stitchers,
and at some point say, I have
all the frames for animation,
I'll just generate it now.
So the fact that we
had this allowed us
to add extra weird stitchers.
And we created this one where
we have the beginning of one
of the videos, then the
jump, then the animation,
and then the end
of another video.
So this starts to
look a little bit more
like "The Matrix,"
which was really cool.
I totally forgot
his name, but he
was helping us record a video,
and he was super excited
about this.
It was lots of fun.
So now we have
pipeline processing.
So we have everything.
It's already done.
We're just missing
doing the thing itself.
Extracting the frame, so
detecting that audio peak
and extracting the
frame, and then
stitching all the
images together
to generate that image.
So how do we do this?
So Matt, our dear
intern, wrote some code
that did exactly this.
And I just modified
it a little bit
to be able to basically
get files from Google Cloud
Storage, process the
video, and then put it
back to Cloud Storage again.
This is the whole code
for the frame extraction.
And the important
thing about this
is that this is the
code that I modified.
A git blame says so.
So there's a bug in this
code, and it's mine.
And I'm using standard deviation
instead of mean for the noise.
And this, basically, instead
of getting the mean power
of the sound on a frame, I'm
getting the standard deviation
of the power on a frame.
And this works as long
as the room is silent,
which is why, the night
before the demo, Ray and I
are trying to figure out, at
the venue at 1:00 AM, what
is going on.
See, we actually figured
out that standard deviation
was just silly, and
it was instead mean.
We changed one function
call, and then we
were all happy again.
Yay.
That was pretty intense.
Then we modified it to
instead of getting something
with standard deviation
and very complex stuff,
we just compute how
noisy a single frame is,
and we choose the noisiest one.
And that single
algorithm just works.
So what do we need to do
to process these things?
Well, we need
something that is going
to be using FFmpeg to
do audio processing.
MoviePy is actually
a Python library that
is a port-- no, not a port.
I forgot the word.
Whatever.
It actually calls behind FFmpeg.
We're going to need
to use Pub/Sub again.
And we're going to need
this to work really quick.
We use Google Compute Engine.
Why?
Well, we want
something that is going
to be running continuously,
and that's not App Engine.
App Engine is for something
that replies to requests.
We want something that
will start the process up,
going to Pub/Sub and say,
give me one new task.
So we use Compute Engine.
We have Compute Engine
everywhere in the world,
it's very fast, and
it's very affordable.
Then on top of that,
you can actually
choose what kind of
machine you want.
So you could say, I want
a machine with 32 cores
and 208 gigabytes of RAM.
And we have that.
But maybe you want
to spend less.
I think it's G1 Micro, which
is like a piece of a processor
or somewhere, and it's
less than 1 cent per hour.
It's super, super cheap.
And that's what you find,
and we have those too.
And then also, you can choose
whatever you feel like.
So basically, you have sliders
and choose more memory,
less memory, more CPU, less.
I'm going to go quite
quick on this one.
But basically, what
we did was, OK,
so I want a bunch of
machines to be running,
and I want those machines
to be managed somehow.
So I'm going to create
this Manage Instance Group.
And a Manage Instance
Group is just
a group that is managed of
instances, as the name implies.
And they're all exactly the
same except for metadata.
The metadata is the only
thing that you can change,
but they run exactly
the same software,
exactly the same
hardware, same OS,
all of those things the same.
Then you have the
Instance Group Manager.
And this is the one that
is going to add or remove
instances as we need.
And this allows us to have
load balancing or scaling.
Then we need an
instance template.
And the instance template
is basically, OK, I
need one more machine,
give me the recipe for it.
So you're going to run an Ubuntu
machine with 32 cores and all
those things, and this
is the startup script.
You can toy with that.
It's very simple to do.
And if you have a
new template, you
can always say, hey,
this is the new template,
please do a rolling update.
And it will just restart,
regularly, those machines, one
after the other, to make
sure that after a while,
all of your machines,
all of your fleet,
is running the new software.
So that's pretty cool.
So you end up with something
which is kind of complex.
But we actually did
this at the beginning.
And since I'm a very special
person, I decided, no, no, no.
This has to run on Docker
because, come on, Docker.
So what I did is I'm just
going to create a Docker
container for the stitcher
and a Docker container
for the extractor.
And now, what I'm doing is every
single time I start one VM,
it's going to be running
CoreOS, because CoreOS
runs Docker by default. I
don't have to install anything.
And then the startup script
is docker run my container.
And it works, which
is really cool.
So we got started, and then we
have 20 machines running just
to manage this load, which
is kind of ridiculous.
Because we're running
on the old world, right?
We're not on this
old, old world where
you have one machine and a
bunch of applications on it.
But we're on right after.
We have a bunch of
virtual machines running
on every single machine,
and every application
runs inside of its
virtual machine.
They're kind of slow.
There's a lot of resources
that are wasted because you're
replicating many of the things
that every single machine is
using.
But since I'm using Docker,
one good thing-- well, you're
using containers, why don't you
put all the containers inside
of a single virtual machine?
And I decided that
that was a good idea.
So we started doing that.
And then it's like, OK, how
many do I want to put in there?
Do I want to put four, five?
No idea.
So as soon as you start
having many containers,
the next step is
container orchestration.
So we went to Google
Container Engine.
And this is what Google
Container Engine looks
like, which is exactly what we
had built from the beginning,
but now, this is
automated, and you
don't have to manage it by
yourself, which is awesome.
And basically,
everything you need to do
is you say, hey,
I want a cluster.
My cluster's going to
have five machines.
These are the kind of machines.
And I want to run 20
of these containers.
Run them wherever you feel like.
And if one of the machines
goes down, don't even tell me.
Just move it away.
Restart the machine
later on, because there's
an Instance Group Manager.
And all of those things
work automatically.
So I like to think
about it as, if you
have Compute Engine,
which is the part where
you have a lot of
flexibility but also DevOps,
and you have App
Engine, where you have
no DevOps but not
as much flexibility,
I like to think that
Container Engine is up there.
Where you have all
the flexibility
you want because
it's got a container,
and you can run
whatever you want in it.
But at the same time,
you have less DevOps
to do because you have all
of the Container Engine
and [INAUDIBLE] is helping you
orchestrate all of those tasks.
So it's a pretty sweet world.
So yeah, Google
Container Engine.
And I'm almost
running out of time,
but that's what we got--
around three times resource
increase, which is pretty good.
At this point, we had spent
enough money on tripods
that this was not that
important anymore,
but still, our manager
was happy for this.
So this is the
whole architecture.
All our files are stored
in Google Cloud storage.
We use App Engine to
process our notifications.
Pub/Sub to manage all the
tasks and smooth the workload.
And then Container Engine to
actually track those tasks.
Time for a fun story.
We did this also in Tokyo.
And we just send the
whole specifications off--
these are all the cables
we need-- to Tokyo,
and then people in
Tokyo bought them.
So the phone, to be able
to detect the audio,
we need this specific cable.
This is a TRS to TRRS thing.
Because we tried to
make them ourselves,
and this is how it looked.
Super pro.
And these didn't work.
So let's use off the shelf,
much better, Google style.
Let's use cheap off
the shelf components
that we can reuse if they break.
So what we did is, OK, we
have the control tablet.
We press the button.
There's a cable
that goes to an amp.
Then that amp sends four cables.
Every single one has a hub.
And then that's 20 phones.
Boom.
Done.
Yeah, doesn't work.
Because you need that cable.
It's a TRS to TRRS adapter.
And what happens if
you don't have it?
Which happened in Tokyo.
Well, you go to the Google
Makerspace in the Tokyo office,
you find a bunch of
resistors, and you
spend the night soldering,
making those amazing
looking cables.
And the demo actually worked.
That was lots of fun.
So in conclusion, I just have
a couple seconds to finish.
We were able to build, in
around two weeks, a demo that,
hardware-wise, yeah, it
worked, but software-wise,
is very robust.
It was very easy to build.
It's actually very
effective to run.
Whenever it's not running,
the autoscaler just shuts down
everything, so there's
no cost accorded
to it other than the storage.
And it was lots of fun.
So thank you for all
the demo builders,
for the team building it and
throwing plushies in the air.
There's a gopher there.
Thank you very much.